everyone Oni house yeah I'm big
mentoring I don't know how to speak can
be so thank you for that
hello this is Lou I'm LuAnn the founding
partner of nutrient capital I'm so glad
to be here to share my story with you so
I was born and raised in China
that's a nice big mentoring and also I'm
not from the big cities you know me
heard about for Dan how Shanghai Beijing
can do no I actually from a place called
Inner Mongolia it's an independent
province in the northern China it's kind
of similar province to get back so we
have our own president in this province
they also have lots of different
minority nationality lives there and I
actually belong to one of the minority
nationality when I think back when I
stopped back I can realize my parents
was the first generation of
entrepreneurs in China they was working
very big government-owned corporations
at that time all the corporations good
one owned by the government but they
quit their job they want to do something
by themselves so young couple decreed
are very good job
leave the in among living the Mongolia
and went to a big city next to Beijing
starter for start-up at that time we
don't call we start out with our small
business but looking back yeah they also
start up but unfortunately they cook out
she could not get a VC funding they
could only like sell their house get
along and the really good thing working
so I really looked up to them and also
when I look at look back I kind of feel
like I inherited the personality from my
birth parents that I would be a risk
taker that's also the reason after I
graduate from my college I decided to
come to United States from my graduate
school so I came to Stanford continued
started engineering that's also the
starting point that
luckily I got this opportunity to
interact with the whole innovation
ecosystem here in the valley I was was
engineering school majoring in mature
sense engineering and I put lots of
automakers as engineering here we are we
have a saying that I met so many like
mature scientists in the VC industry and
the risk that always good and bad which
means it's really hard to find a good
academia research direction this build
the omnibus conductorette has become
venture capitalists so I was majoring in
her science so I did lots of research
during that field I did research in nano
zinc film bowel sensor even they show my
own battery doctor is I don't like Tesla
battery so luckily I wonder my patent
technology got supported from University
so just encourage me maybe you could do
a start-up by yourself to me that was
brand new although there are so many
undergrads and graduate student at
Stanford from engineering school they
did start off the job hop and they saw
something really cool but as a Chinese I
still grew up from a pretty traditional
family although I choose some different
jobs but I don't know whether it's a
right way to go to to at such a young
age to start my company but that
mentioned earlier I was a risk taker I
feel excited when there's a futurist and
huge opportunity from so I took it I
started my company I was thinking how
hard would it be turned out to be super
hard I was super super hard not only
because it's a startup company also
because I was working on one level
so has application by diabetes
diagnostic so I was working on medical
device company I don't know whether we
have founder here working in healthcare
industry or running a medical device
company to me was super hard not only
the product and technology that's a
product because we had to a hundred
percent no problem the problem is and
was the immigrant that the first year
second year I came to United States and
I was dealing with this most complicated
system in United States which is health
care
we have mutual company they have Big
Pharma medical device company they also
have disappeared esse FDA approval
process so I have to start not only
Rendon company also kind of refresh
myself try to learn all these new things
every day do with lots of like this very
experience at the a regulator and that I
made lots of mistakes and luckily I kind
of make them up and pushing forward and
the company work the product work and
that was a miserable time frame that I
went through with us that many years and
but unluckily yeah I got off from back
after I graduate from Stanford I also
got my company acquired a biotech
medical device company although I had a
dementia had a major a time when running
my company because so much of work and
also I got lots of challenge a Detroit
are challenged every day I think I
really don't have time to question
myself whether I I could do it because I
don't have time when I will come I don't
have to gasping then that's a that's a
life but when I sold my company I feel
feel a little bit sad because it's not
your baby
no matter is a good baby is a beautiful
baby is a naughty baby it's okay so for
so much is your baby
not American sitting so now when I
become a VC Eliza when I talk about
founder when they got an offer for
finding that company I kind of
understand wedding it's really hard for
them to let it go so it was a really
really interesting experience so after
that I I start to I also want to give
myself a break so I went to a large
corporation borrowing semiconductor
companies doing poor dumb marketing
meanwhile I also got the opportunity to
become a venture partner at the Silicon
Valley VC firm doing emerging technology
girls a late-stage investment ironically
will now with the founder
I hate VC I really don't like we see I
think yes I got them could visit the
poor me meanwhile also met couple of
likely means many superman' receiving
interact with my presentation they
challenged my gender my age they also
try to make her micromanagement my
company so I think them but and but I
become one of them hello so when I start
doing my investment I originally I want
to try to use this opportunity and
platform to to see different things I
think I did a lot of things with my
company doesn't like us at the
technology area I was at I also use this
opportunity I want you I want you to use
that opportunity to see different
innovation in different category and
along the way I also kind of make me
because now at that time I start cooking
the VC having to myself I start thinking
from the VC perspective and I gradually
feel I can do appreciate all the basic
gave me hard time when I first got a
company because they sell me stop me
from like going to the wrong direction
and also the keep challenge me make me
become better the kind of feel is okay
if I'm gonna continue doing this job
because there's a way that I could
become an entrepreneur family receives
it specially because I have this
experience as a firm enterpreneur so I
don't I know their language I know their
the company's life cycle I know there is
no perfect startup I know every day's
mission is still with problems so I see
PwC health under deal with their problem
and also try to be the go-to person
within your health and then I found out
maybe during this stage is hard because
they stages capital where you have to
fight against tough with partners
sometimes with founder sometime to
afford for the only interest so in 2014
I got this good opportunity from the
other capital support so I start my own
VC firm Eugene capital so that's a
starting point that I really could do a
firm and also build up a team based on
the same mission and same personality
and also same momentum that we really
want to help founder at early stage so
far we have 38 popular company under
investment and up and our management
right now and I remember three years ago
after I become VC run my own firm
there's after another sell from New York
came over to Vida to do a interview for
me and he told me a number which kind of
surprised me a lot of it he said oh the
ratio female partner in VC industry is
only like six percent I think now grow
up a little bit not to seven percent and
then it's a huge job
so since then I'll start thinking about
among my life I always kind of got used
to be the non special one that the fewer
small percent of the community like I
choose to start engineering when most
girls coming hard to do literature
accounting in China and I decided to
come to the United States and decide to
continue doing a startup company very
few female founder that's a reason when
I heard organizer told me most of them
most of the audience today are females
and I was so happy so happy to see so
many female founder here and when I
start working on the VC I feel same
thing I got this racial number so when I
look back I just have lots of very
interesting stories relate to this for
example when I went to Japan to have a
meeting with our customer I have the
team reported me locally but I found I'm
the only female in the room and they
don't feel comfortable I was there they
just pretend I'm a shadow and they talk
to each other and that they'd want to
bypass me and when I went to the big
semiconductor company Europe and I told
them oh I want to go to retro and he
said ah let me ask the front desk lady
and then I found out I only have one
restroom in the first floor of this
five-star rich beauty and I remember i
after i become the VCI always coming
invitation to speak at a conference
become the speaker our panelists it was
so interesting that there was a panel
the module retracts at first you master
how do you think about the trend of
Technology second one how do you help
company was like uber type of business
model the third one Oh like how to think
about the IPO of snapchat like potential
IPO of snapchat and to me how do you
balance your life and the work I'm like
I'm not only one half the balance has to
have the work-life balance
but let's say that that's a few times we
have for for female special young female
no matter its entrepreneur investor you
have to balance your life but there's
normally for fund investor to balance
your life when you're running a company
where we're helping with the startup
company so I kind of start thinking like
how I could better handle debt I do not
do it very well when I first started I
kind of gradually for them I try to hide
my age I don't want to people know that
I'm only 28 I want you to think I'm
older I try to dress like like a semi
gender things like let them know you're
that okay I'm a female but along the way
I think it is actually not work and I
should not work and I remember that fear
will stop because interval to me and the
journalist asked me how do you handle
your time I think May 1908 very well but
and what I'm going to do in the future
is I won't try to argue with anyone have
a CEO type because they won't work I
will do something I will get thing than
to prove them wrong
and also to myself as I realize that I
don't need to care about your time
because some people do you still type as
a label to recognize the word and the
community they don't really have the bad
intention for people really have the bad
intention no matter what you do out talk
to them they may change very little but
why should I care that's their problem
not mine so why should I do something
for other problems other than just be
myself by starting myself
I just realized I'm not just making all
the decision and to other work based on
what I want who I want to be and things
I want to follow so that color is I'm so
glad to see so many female founder here
today the housing other who is increase
the ratio of female BC we need more
female founders and when you get a big
asset please join us and join the VIP
industry that get more percentage of the
female we see in this industry and look
for to that thank you
[Applause]